what brings you
to Colorado okay 1983. I'm
a stone cold Criminal
I got nothing going on for me
what is the day in the life you wake up
wake up wake up [__] go to the deli get
two eggs on a bun and then look at the
paper see who's playing tonight so
you've got a chance to gamble everything
like we did everything so I get up in
the morning go get two eggs bacon sunny
side up whatever and while you're there
you're looking at the New York Times The
Daily News you're getting lines for the
[__] games then while you're sitting
there some guy comes in and says hey man
I may need an ounce of coke for Friday
boom I got my pigeon for the day let's
get this [__] started and then
after you get them the ounce of coke
somebody else comes to you and said I
Rob the truck today can you help me
unload it'll drive it to Pittsburgh that
type of [__] like it was just I had no
job I had no parents
so there's nobody disappoint nobody
disappoint I had nothing to lose so when
I would do things with my friends I go
listen
if you get in trouble run I'll take the
pinch because I got no family I don't
give a [__]
so everybody loves doing crimes again so
yeah because uh you know I'm not gonna
write you out yeah I got no reason to
write yeah so that's how what I became
were you associated with like a crime
family in New York no so just you and a
couple of guys with my own crime family
I was on my own you know my crime watch
was get up in the morning and you're
gonna steal time
you know whatever they're gonna you're
gonna do then I got a job working for
one of my mother's friends
and uh
118th and like third by the market by
Spanish harlemen and we used to do
numbers there and one day I was like you
know what this is great I'm getting 150
a day I'm 20 years old but what am I
gonna do when I'm 30. and this goes
under and now I gotta go find the job
what am I going to tell somebody that
I've been running numbers for the last
30 years so I was in a bar one night and
a friend of mine came in from high
school and he was living
in South Colorado at the time which is a
suburb of Aspen and I'm like thug I got
nothing going on here I just tried to
rob a bookie I got attacked by the dog I
had I was walking around with a man with
a glove on because I got when the cops
are chasing me I got my hand caught on
the fence and they ripped the guts out
so I had I didn't go for stitches that
night because I was on valium so I had
to [__] put a a toilet paper roll in
here with a black glove and that's how I
walked around for like two months
so not only did I have problems but now
I had a black glove on like Han from
Enter the Dragon like the [__]
so it was just like you know what I got
nothing going on here
let me give Colorado a try when I was a
kid I loved ABC News and they always
said you know
six o'clock Eastern five o'clock Pacific
mountain time that always [__] with me
like what the [__] is Mama
what the [__] is Mountain Time so when
the opportunity came I [__] ended up
going to Basalt with Jimmy his brother
George and this guy named Mike Duffy and
we're still off tight Wow Mike Duffy's
in Texas Jimmy Burkle died my brother in
Georgia's in L.A what still thing okay
so you're all going to Colorado we're
all going to college all you guys kind
of involved in the streets is there are
all you guys Hustlers at this time
Mike Duffy was a Savage like me George
Berkel I just graduated from Brown his
classmate was Kennedy wow all right and
his brother
Jimmy my buddy who took me there was
another genius he went to the Air Force
Academy and got thrown out for knocking
somebody out so he had no life now so I
ended up going to Boulder when I ended
up going to Basalt which is a a subsidy
of Aspen like 20 miles down the road
and then after a while we moved to
Snowmass Village and somebody told me
here I had no GED I just quit school my
senior year right and somebody goes go
to Colorado Mountain College and take
some classes so I go you know what [__]
it I go up then I took 12 credits like
uh six credits my first semester then I
would take six credits six credits six
credits even though I was [__]
stealing Coke doing coke skiing I still
took
I still taught those classes
every criminal some leisure activities
okay okay so when you're going out there
you're like are we are you looking at
this city and you're going these are
going to be a bunch of easy licks they
never seen this coming and we're gonna
absolutely not at all I went out there
to change my own different life okay but
after six more weeks you're like what am
I doing it's too easy I'm installing
[__] panel for eight bucks an hour I
can just selling eight ball make 200. or
and then I kept on the control for a
long time and then
I got there like May no April of 83 and
I kept my secret under control till like
September and then I had to let loose
for football season what do you mean but
I just started robbing a little
businesses that would leave that doors
open
when I came in here I was talking to
this gentleman who I've met before we
have a mutual friend yeah named [__]
yeah in 85 I lived in [__] Aspen
because I I stayed in assault
until February of 84th and then I had to
leave and we'll get to that some other
time and I came back here which was a
big mistake wait wait tell me why you
had to leave we had to leave because I
got out of control from September I
started robbing little Chiefs that shows
and little jewelry stores but by [__]
uh she's in children
like liquor stores like little things
yeah yeah I'm going to get like a grand
and three bottles I was a [__]
demented yeah I Was a Serial Thief but
like stick up Robin nah just break it in
that night and then all of a sudden now
I'm robbing a jewelry store with a
friend of mine and then I had a plan
with another friend of mine steady
Freddie to rob the bank on Christmas Eve
with snowmobiles this guy was crazy so I
had these people around me and I'm like
wait a second I'm right back to where
the [__] I started yeah I gotta get out
of here so I went back here and this
place was on fire